wait you have a ring on dr. Mike here
with the lovely Ava from my life as Ava
we're gonna talk about Ava's disbeliefs
and beliefs about medicine and we're
gonna set him straight
these aren't planned by the way so first
question is everyone always says like
when you go out to eat they're like oh
don't touch that sugar because sugar
gives you cancer leaving water balls in
your car cost cancer drink out of a
glass cup plastic cups cause cancer are
all those things
Able's like caused me cancer like should
I just live my life not touching
anything if you constantly live your
life thinking whatever you do you're
gonna get a cancer that's not a way to
live life
drink me out of plastic how bad is it
it's really not that bad I mean unless
you're using a cheap piece of plastic
and you're reusing water bottles all the
time you're throwing the microwave yes
that's not great if you just live in a
balanced normal way you're gonna be fine
one down that makes me feel better
question dose question two like I'm a
girl which means that I can get breast
cancer I'm still really young and I'm
tiny and like I've got these small boobs
what time my life should I start
wondering if I should go the doctor to
like check up on all those things guys
get breast cancer too it's not just for
women really what you can do as a female
is starting at the age of 40 you want to
start getting mammograms right do you
know what a mammogram is yeah come on
they like touch your boobs so a
mammogram is a scan that looks at your
breast tissue that tells you you have
some sort of irregularity there before
the age of 40 what you should do is you
should be able to know what's normal for
your breast
hey this bump wasn't here before this
pain wasn't here before this
discoloration wasn't here also important
to know if you had someone very young
and your family had breast cancer that
might lead me to start testing you a
little bit earlier are you doing a great
job so far man I learned I two-for-two
knowledge to get to tomorrow I have
friends that model and they always drink
carrot juice before a day of like a
shoot to make their eyes sparkle Sparkle
okay
carrot juice does not make your eyes
sparkle carrot juice does contain a lot
of vitamin A if you have enough vitamin
A you're
vision will stay healthy the reason we
say that is if you have too low in
vitamin A your vision gets worse some of
these people they go overboard and they
start doing things too much yeah you
know what happens if you to make carrots
you turn orange you turn orange so if I
eat a lot of carrots like it's right
here look at carrot it yes you'll have a
carrot in a keratin okay so I'm allergic
to cats and whenever I'm with my cat and
robic cat how you learned your parents
love cat I love her so much but when she
gets a lot touchy like I have to take
benadryl because you know like I need to
clear my sinuses I'm a back pain but I
want to drink wine later like champagne
for like a mimosa but I'm like on
aspirin when you take any sort of
medicine and it says don't drink alcohol
am I going to die by drinking alcohol I
will answer it in a very universal way
will you die from one glass of alcohol
with aspirin or benadryl or anything
over-the-counter no is it good to drink
alcohol with a lot of these pills
probably not why aspirin give my back
Kawai aspirin like oh no I watch TV air
commercials you see what happens why not
like a set amount of Finn like Tyler
said a benefit tylenol no no Tyler don't
feel like a baby on any hardcore stuff a
hard I need that 500 milligram tylenol
is only a pain and fever reducer but
does not work on inflammation and
aspirin actually works on your platelets
[Music]
little circle things that air in your
blood that do what their circles they're
not really circles there's a little you
know like ringlets think ringlets sure
kids at home don't drink alcohol with
drugs I'm just saying this to her
because she's too crazy with partying
I'm an adult she's it almost an adult
I'm gonna don't you're not even 21
minutes no you're not
ID check how easy is it to get addicted
to something like nyquil or painkillers
like does it take five days does it take
a month of doing it daily cuz I'm not
trying to get addicted off painkillers
cuz my back hurt one day and
suddenly I'm addicted when I wake up
addiction to over-the-counter pain
medications like tylenol advil it can
happen you technically can't get
addicted to anything I mean there's sex
addictions out there so people can get
addicted to literally anything but is it
likely no because generally those
medications don't have addictive
properties meaning that when your body
doesn't get them your body doesn't go
through withdrawal opioid medications
like oxycodone percocet though is you
can get addicted from one-time use so
it's very important that you only taken
one absolutely absolutely necessary both
well I have been working out a lot more
I could tell god she's hiding my arm
behind yeah I have been eating healthy
and I've been trying like get my
nutrients but being a vegan I think it's
maybe hard to get a lot of my vitamins
maybe I've been taking a multivitamin
thinking that's like good for me
vitamins for the average healthy person
a multivitamin vitamin D vitamin E all
the vitamins out there taking them does
not help you stay healthy longer doesn't
prevent any illness doesn't cure
anything unless you happen to be that
small my new population that has a
deficiency how important it is it to get
a tetanus shot I like to hang out Hawaii
surf you know cut my foot on some rocks
whatever okay where were we
you like to cut your foot on rock see
that's a new teenage thing that you guys
are doing now rock cut really no okay
sometimes I only come a foot on a rock
and you know you'd bandage it up
whatever salt water cleans it out I'm a
mountain man truth when is the last time
you got a tetanus shot I can't remember
come on
the last time I've done your vaccines
done and you remember you see what
happens tetanus shot you needed every
ten years okay so it's not even a
vaccine that you need to get it so often
but now we're giving a special type of
tetanus shot where it's not only
protecting you from tetanus it's called
a Tdap it also protects you from
diphtheria and pertussis fancy words for
ptosis which causes whooping cough
yeah another thing about tetanus why
risk getting a horrible tetanus
infection in your leg you can get
gangrene and lose a toe a finger arm
okay I want the sexy get the tetanus
shot it's like a little bit I have heard
a lot of people do yoga and sailing ever
since I started yoga my health has gone
so much better and my back is healed so
it's like I'm hearing all these things
about natural things that you can do
with working out and stuff that gets rid
of like health things can you actually
cure medical conditions and pain like
medicating working out eating like kale
kale is cool whoever is the marketer
that made kale superfood is a genius if
you can do the same for my instagram and
youtube and Ava's as well please do it
because you kill the tail yeah yeah
Callie Oh number one diet and exercise
cannot only help cure some of your
illnesses but they can also prevent
those who exercise have a lower risk of
getting depression those who exercise
have a lower risk of developing
Alzheimer's lately later in life you can
lower your cholesterol levels better
that you can than with medicine just by
exercising there's no such thing as a
cure-all
there's no Fountain of Youth but
exercise comes closest yes do yoga do
sports make your heart go crazy make
your heart happy yes I love green juices
like love green juices love all the
detox juices and all that do detox is
really work and are they worth doing
Apple kale banana spinach ginger is that
actually gonna like help me juices
themselves are not bad but they do
contain a lot of sugar so if you're
diabetic or eating a lot of sugar in
general you have to keep that in mind as
you probably know that in order to make
a glass of orange juice it doesn't just
take one orange right it takes a few
also when you eat a fruit you get some
fiber along with it when you eat fiber
it makes you feel fuller and also
prevents the absorption of some of that
sugar so you don't absorb it and it
doesn't go into your blood and you drink
the juice it just goes straight into
your body gets absorbed as simple sugars
and can cause you
become diabetic if you have it too often
they have some great vitamins some great
minerals so juice every now and then
again with them reason balance it's fun
but detoxes what a marketing play your
body naturally cleanses itself your skin
sheds its lighting every day your
intestinal lining sheds and your body
replaces it with new lining there's no
need to detox my humble opinion and
based on what research has shown because
that's where my opinion comes from
there's no benefit to doing any of this
but if you want to have a green juice
have it after the gym because that's the
time it's okay to have some sugar
well Lena I didn't know you were such a
curious soul I am very curious good to
see that the younger generation has a
thirst for medical knowledge for
knowledge
everybody should tune into my life is
Ava's channel because there's also a
cool video that we made earlier today
that you love on my channel and if you
obviously have any questions any
comments about things we talked about
today leave a comment down below I'll
make sure to answer it and if you
haven't yet click that subscribe button
[Music]
basketball guy fouled me then he's like
that wasn't even felled and I said but
wait look at that he's like okay fine